welcome to this video this is round five
coverage of the Gaussian off memorial
from Azerbaijan and yeah this is the
final round of the first turn of this
event it's a double round-robin so each
player faces them each other to x and
yeah the game of the day is again a game
by the world champion among the scars
are playing whitey against team or a job
off them he should be the number two
playoff azerbaijan right yeah i think he
should um yeah the other two games they
also were interesting i mean it wasn't
so easy this choice actually um nakamura
played a draw against sagar coyoacán
inin in a game where he most of the time
held some slight advantage but somehow
it never really got to the point where
he could gappu so big problems that
kayak in them got into serious trouble
at the end of term it was a draw so
probably the deserved result the other
game was a very long affair between
mamedyarov playing white and Kara wanna
playing black corolla we're defeated
cards in the round before certainly
looking for a good result too yeah try
to too yeah maybe expand this lead but
it went in a totally different direction
mayara played a real line of the
Greenfeld and quite quickly corona went
for a pawn sacrifice which really did
not get any great results he was a porn
down it looked like him he has decent
drawing chances based on opposite
colored bishops maybe but it was always
better for widen at the end mama dr
won this game after some 90 moves about
90 bucks so great result from mamedyarov
really had suffered in the event losing
two games already so we making a sort of
a mini come back with the win so let's
look at cosmic job of how does the world
champion react to the loss yesterday
this tough loss in the villain that he
suffered against kawana yeah okay we
went we got the default on the board and
the job off is playing the Kings Indian
which can only be yeah welcomed by the
fence I guess he I mean not not even
only the fence off of him him personally
but in general of chess fans because
Roger of office really the absolute best
Kings Indian player of today's chess I
mean Kasparov retired in 2005 and he's
sort of the the legend of the Kings
Indian but if you look at modern day
chats the last couple of years raja
baath really put this opening back on
the map and away and had excellent
results so it's good to see him playing
this again he had also tried some other
openings for example in this world
championship candidates match in Kazan
in 2011 year played the classical Queens
gambit against chronic so a totally
different opening so let's see Carlton
is going for this line the night ii to
line the sometimes known as the Kurama
variation or kramer variation which is
in no way related to cosmo kramer from
seinfeld just if you think that he
invented something you know that's not
the case um I think chroma was I'm not
quite sure I think a Dutch player lots o
Joe and player that's tricky I could
have looked that up well not g2 let's
call it the night g2 line um yeah what's
the idea of the slide we could they see
that after castles 93 this night is
routed to g3 and yeah what
the point really the night is doing a
couple of things on g3 it covers a form
that's important of course if I was a
sensitive spot and it looks at very
important squares f5 and h5 those
squares are especially important in
relation to blacks plan of playing f5
later we see that now a job of goes 45
this is not the only possible setup but
of course the most classical one in the
Kings Indian with e5 and now we see at
some point blank maybe wants to play a 5
and the night is placed exactly on a
square to look at this at this spot f5
there's also h5 as a critical square
where black in some cases likes to put
is night to prepare not to prepare a 5
and of course with the white knight on
g3 this is entirely possible so there
are some points related to the night to
g3 another point is this will see
quickly yeah black is setting up in a
typical fashion here with a 5 and 9 a-6
to prepare night jump to c5 we now see H
for being played this is really a point
of the night g3 system 92 g3 system
white tries to play the pawn to h5 and
in this way sort of yeah playing a sort
of a preemptive strike on the kingside
he does not want to play for meeting a
tech necessarily it might happen it
might happen if black is totally
careless like h5 there should be 3 22
yeah this is this way Bishop age six and
then push down the age file but this
might only happen if black is totally
careless whites main idea is to get in
only age 52 sort of disturb like on the
King side and make sure that f5 is not
easily
playable yeah the best response it seems
is what Raja will played he just played
h5 strop stopping that in its tracks now
Bishop g5 was played yeah in this
particular position black must be aware
of one possibility if everything's set
up correctly for that white might think
of sacrificing on h5 and establishing
the somewhat somewhat inconvenient pin
I'm not sure that this is really working
now I just want to show the idea let's
say c6 and why it would take I think
this is not correct but I want to want
to show the general idea or maybe it is
correct know that I think of it Black is
very very slow here yeah the thing is
look at this this is a very strong pin
the night is set to put pressure on f6
and black is not really getting his
pieces back to defend maybe you can try
that play 98 but yeah even this move is
a possibility here after taking and
castles this this is very dangerous yeah
well this strike on h5 is it it's a
possibility so Roger Bobb is playing
Queen e8 to stop that all together and
the queen is I mean stop that all
together means that after this now there
is no pin simply so black can take and
is perfectly fine so Queenie 8 it's also
a good idea because it places the Queen
on a very versatile square e 8 this look
in this direction which can come in
handy we'll see that later in the game
and it also looks at this pawn chain
which makes lots of sense as black still
wants to play a five at some point and
then the h5 porn might become a
sensitive spot and blacks camp so the
queen is over protecting this pawn I
know it looks like X raped through two
pawns but black will play a five
eventually and you can easily imagine
f-5e takes FG take seven then the Queen
directly defense h5 so Queenie a deserve
a good spot here for the Queen ok Queen
d2 was played and non night c5 young and
add a quick look at the database there
are not so many examples of this
position so it was a bit tough for me to
figure out what exactly white some
planets here of course I have some
experience of in Kings Indian structures
and also in somewhat similar structures
but to be honest I have played let's say
the Arabic variation or the sameish and
there I never really play age for simply
because um it feels like it yeah it
gives away some sort of flexibility um I
think in this position what I would
actually suggest he is 4 y 2 player 3
because it didn't do that he played long
castles but hopes that was bad and what
too quick um my suggestion would be to
play a three here and take control over
the g4 square after castles what he
played there was nigh G form and this is
Ted uncomfortable I mean this is hanging
you cannot player three blunders in
exchange and if you try to cover f2
there is f6 and this is also not too too
great where's the bishop going you don't
really want to go to e3 you can take on
g4 but all this is this you could have
done without playing look everyone so
after Knight g4 he actually 21 g4
and I don't think that this is too great
for whites to be honest I think maybe
you should have really tried to play f3
Black is suffering a bit from lack of
space so this kind of exchanges I think
aren't quite fine for black so
preventing nagi 4s may be a good idea
and in the long run I think maybe white
can can try something like let's say
long castles night somewhere here or not
sure to f1 and maybe prepare g4 at some
point I mean this is all about palm
brakes and I'm not quite sure what palm
break right is aiming form after you
have played H form it is somewhat tricky
to play for f4 for example because you
weaken g4 so enormously I mean I'm not
talking about the move right here this
looks a totally insane but I mean in the
long run now F form does not seem like a
great idea due to the weakness on on g4
and well what kind of sorry not c5 is on
the what what kind of idea this is why
have I mean if you cannot play really f4
then the only pawn break on the kingside
would be g4 if you try to play them um
yeah and the other idea of course a wide
is still to play em to play on the
queenside but this is yeah after you've
played H foil you're not going to Castle
short in this position after h4 was
played so why do cows along and this
does not mean that expanding on the
queenside is out of the picture quite
often this is in fact a valid idea even
with the King on the queenside but this
takes a very long time so I think f3 was
a bit a bit more interesting maybe after
castles naija file white took as
mentioned there is hardly anything
better takes and three now and Bishop d7
back yeah and one problem is the knight
on f6 here now we went to deform it
netted black the bishop pair and with
the night gone black is really quick
ready to play a five and yeah well to be
honest I have a slight issue here with
this position I'm not quite sure what
white is aiming for if black is getting
in f5 him in he's managed to play as
standard break and whites play seems
slow at best I mean he played Bishop to
e3 now which makes some sense the bishop
is not really doing much on g5 and white
at least this is posing a threat here
possibly a threat of really capturing
this can be a threat if black can for
example place let's say I'm just to
illustrate a black players somewhat
nothing moves lacking h7 oops there is
this idea of capturing and possibly
going d6 no that's ruka King edge seven
it it prepares this one I should allow
that so King edge 7 I just want to
illustrate the idea so let's go to h
eight yeah and now these six breaking
through in the middle and this is a bit
inconvenient you cannot play c6 because
94 wins immediately looking at those
squares and if you take you get a
position where the bishops might become
relatively silly pieces and white gets
the lights on on decent squares in the
middle yeah this is an idea so raja
baath plate b6 simply to to prevent this
once and for all so Bishop c5 now is
useless because of the B poem recapture
it didn't do that of course played King
to be one this is hard to do without in
the long run King be one so King h7
displayed yeah this is a prep move for a
five and Quincy to trying to look at
this sensitive square yeah and now of
course a4 was played
five I'm sorry I actually I looked and
looked at this rock I thought he played
at five but ok this is coming coming
anyway he took this a bit of space on
the queenside first 92 and now I five
yeah the night on g3 it wasn't doing
much I mean there was his justification
to have it on g3 putting pressure on
edge five but as mentioned the Queen
from me ADA some was sufficiently
covering that anyway so he retreated to
e to F five yeah and now this is really
a tough position what should why do now
I mean with the porn on a form it's
tough to get in before and where exactly
is why it's active play this looks quite
comfortable already for black he took
black took with the porn yeah well
Bishop f5 it looks it looks tempting at
first because it goes some yeah it gives
on the sensitive diagonal white ok must
respond 94 of course and this seems
fairly solid for white it's tough in
this type of position wyd will play this
next very tough would like to open it up
he's got no problems whatsoever but it's
difficult to make any progress GTX f is
just the more dynamic choice and this
might intend to play f4 and Bishop f5 so
cards and play some rook h3 first at the
moment there's this pin going King edge
8 now threatening f4 and now I played f4
himself to just stop this once and for
all yeah the rookie h3 move it intense
this type of maneuver using the rook but
still after a form I mean it's pretty
obvious I think that why does not have
any sort of advantage out of the opening
black enjoys a position with with two
bishops it's got a pretty good center
and while the King is sometimes an issue
it's a bit airy here but why does
nowhere near with any pieces to to
attack and a very important point is
that after F for no real job of went 494
and this is just a very strong move
centralizing the night and asking white
an important question what is your next
move it's not so easy now for four wide
to play maybe he should have gone for
some yeah some sort of prophylactic
moves ein yeah let's say a 3-2
argument's sake it's not exactly great
to weaken your queen side more but oops
a4a 3 was an additional idea and this is
just trying to in a way to stay and do
nothing maybe this is what what should
have done I mean very tough Carlton
didn't want to to play such a such a
relatively passive position and went for
something else which was an interesting
idea I mean it's not like it was not
working totally not working he took on
e4f takes e4 attacking the rook and now
Luke to g3 yeah try to pressurize the h5
porn so a job of plays Bishop to g4 yeah
and now i look at this position I mean
black has an excellent spot here for
other for the bishop it pins the night
and black threatens to take on f4 just
winning the game um yeah it it turns out
that white only has one playable or
continuation here and this is what can't
play it he exchanged he is sacrificed
the exchange on g4 and then played with
f5 this was the plan behind this rook
Knight takes e4 rook to e3 maneuver
and it seemed that he was quite
confident that he has got that he will
get sufficient compensation I think if
you look at the position after Luke
takes a five-night g3 with the tempo
look back and queen takes there is some
justification for this for this idea I
mean white has very nice pieces the
Queen on e4 this is also a good piece
only three and the night can jump to f5
on the right moment to h5 if black queen
is between the decides to move there is
also G form as a potential weakness to
attack at the moment it is hanging so
what might might take it if black is not
taking care taking care of that on the
other hand it's a whole exchange it's
not that's not not a little material
investment and it's not like blackest
without any play himself we now see that
Jarvis going here to cover the pod
doesn't want to give it away immediately
now count played a three and very
important to notice that he had much
more time on the clock raja baath was
down to about 15 16 minutes but still in
this position here he found very strong
and end key move really he now played
them the move b5 and this is an
additional benefit of the Queen it was
formerly only aid this some other
direction of the Queen it sometimes
supports the b5 advance advance and this
is in fact very strong here oops I just
wanted to get rid of the
the arrows well now it's not worked
strangely enough it didn't at first um
the the important thing for black is you
need to have some some counter play and
open lines for the rooks and this is
what the b5 is doing on white now has
very very big difficulties in
maintaining control the whole sacrifice
is based on controlling squares
long-term like a four by the Queen maybe
later the night yeah just the white
wants to have a stable position and
maybe slowly get some make some progress
maybe h5 group here rook h4 root G for
it all takes time and what black needs
to do in each term in a way accelerate
proceedings and open up the position for
the rooks and this is what b5 is doing
um what should why do now if you take
for example black can we recapture here
and quickly get plain this is also
weakness and note that one important
point is the queen is looking nice only
four but well should you ever move it
you must really reckon with a 5-2 e form
and this bishop will get exceptionally
strong the capture only five is not
really helping him yeah katal tried to
play c5 p.m. intending to maybe even
push further but black is just capturing
that and of course he wants to open the
position there is no use in keeping it
close in any way Saudi takes d5 is the
right move and now h5m was tried yeah if
white takes on c5 there is the very
strong reply regret for so this bishop
cannot really move from e3 without any
problem this is in a way also the
problem of the whole sacrifice I mean
this is just it's it's it's more of a
defensive sacrifice you cannot really
do much with your pieces white has some
active posts but this concrete counter
play with b5 as its really getting
getting very difficult for wider to
handle in the press conference if I read
this correctly card said that he
underestimated the b5 idea and when it
was played recognized that that he has
some some trouble now okay well h5 was
tried trying to use the h-bond you see
for keeping this pawn and now aged six
be sure to f6 Bishop c5 all this looks
very very normal look at seven and rook
f1 yes and here we come to a very
important point in this game this rook
f1 move um is actually setting up a very
serious threat that black needs to
attend to why does threatening to
sacrifice on f6 and this in most cases
wouldn't yeah it's not like a wider
saving himself it's very often just
leading to win if black is playing just
for example roof like rook g8 yeah white
will take rook takes Queen takes yeah
it's a tempo on the rook and the big
threat is Bishop e7 and this is so
strong connected with night moves even
that white will ya win this f6 look for
nothing and then we went in with a
direct attack on the Kings this is now
totally exposed so rook takes f6 is a
strong thread and there is only really
one defensive move and this is play poor
job of this is rupee 8 yeah note that he
was down on the clock ready but some
position is needed rook e8 after that
this is pointless as
there is no Queenie 5 and you really
need the five-part to open up the
diagonal yeah he tried to increase
pressure later with this only five but
just this is useful Bishop g5 plate yeah
why does not want to exchange so night
f5 yeah and here another key spot Black
has some more than one good move
available but only one move is really am
killing it in a way and this is c6 and
it's found by a job of very strong it
attacks the d5 pawn and if why it takes
there is creed III and after that why
does just completely lost this is very
very uncomfortable pin on the night and
the deep on that's too much black is an
exchange up anyway so the oldest is just
on top of that so white cannot take yeah
and if white cannot take what exactly
are you playing that's a big problem he
went from Bishop to d6 yeah you can look
at pawn to d6 but what are you doing
after that attacking the night and it
has nowhere to go what can I can give
this check but after after this it turns
out that this is just falling yeah
Bishop d6 was tried and now you should a
fourth again a strong move but Java
played a very very strong game here it
was not like that not all of his moves
were let's say rocket science and then
there were yeah it was possible to find
all of it but he did so in very little
time and against the world champion so
just just a very good job yeah 97 lost
righty this was hanging and what
what exactly are you doing besides 97 so
this was played Queen D 698 and now
queen takes d5 we see that black has
returned the exchange but yeah if we do
a pawn count this is six points against
four and the big issue is how despite
them even now avoid the Queen trade it
simply not possible really this is also
a stranded piece so queen with queens
were traded and now about this pawn this
pawns are very strong yeah g3 first you
might think okay isn't black just losing
a PCM with this pin yeah this is the
case but a job of it correctly seen that
here those two pawns and this pawns
there are just stronger than the night
the night is in a way stranded on the
8th cals managed to put it somewhat back
in the game but those some protected
passes are are too strong yeah and now
the king is even supporting proceedings
yeah ng3 is coming check yeah that after
King g-form here um the hot champion
resigned yeah what a turn of events in
this in this tournament after CalNet
started with two get two wins and really
a excellent chess really he he got a
draw in round three and then lost two
games in a row he lost with black
yesterday against kawana and now even
with white against raja baath so he's
really in some bad shape suddenly quite
remarkable um I think people looked up
that the last time that car had lost two
games in a row was in 2010 so
almost four years ago and he does not
lose often at all I mean really this is
lost yesterday was the first after
almost a year of of being undefeated and
now as even two defeats in a row and
well and it's always tough to criticize
the the really clearly best player at
the moment but this really looked like a
bit of an uninspired game to me I mean
white never really had anything from the
start and it it just never felt right
for what I mean it quickly was almost
yeah forced to sacrifice his exchange
and it was mostly yeah it was born out
of necessity more than anything else so
something's not right at the moment here
so yeah today is a day off and we'll see
what happens in the next turn let's have
a look at the standing though the leader
now in this tournament is tim raja baath
he played a four drawers and one today
so it's leading the tournament with the
plus one score very good result at the
moment caruana also was in good shape
after winning yesterday but he lost
today against Mammadyarov so kawada has
on fifty percent countless on fifty
percent so i'm in a camera also fifty
percent so the tournament is this is
wide open of course Calvin can also
still win it but he has two black games
after the the rest day on Friday and
this will be a very tough in this
current shape for whatever reason he is
in that shape there are sometimes really
days where you you cannot cannot really
yeah get a game going I mean it just
happens but so 2 times in a row is quite
rare for such a such an excellent player
ok so i hope you enjoyed the coverage of
today's game i'll be back on
saturday to have a look at the sixth
round the first round of the of the
second term thanks for watching